I just bought a total strangers diary
off the Internet oh she's inside my head
it's going badly one weird thing you can
buy on eBay is a stranger's diary you
can bid on total strangers most personal
thoughts
most of the diaries you find on eBay are
from 50 to 100 years ago or more but I
want to see if I can find a diary from
recent times something that was written
in like the last 20 years okay I found a
diary from the early 2000s it's from
2001 to 2005 written by someone who
lived in Illinois you have to assume
that the person who wrote the diary
probably when they wrote it had no idea
anyone would ever be reading it I don't
know what I'm gonna find in these
Diaries what if it's like dear diary
today I murdered the starting price is
495 gonna try bidding six dollars and
see what happens somebody else wants
this diary so I've been outbid and I'm
in a bid war I'm gonna increase my
maximum bid from six dollars to $60
hopefully it doesn't go up more from
that two more people are trying to bid
on this diary things are getting intense
I bid a hundred dollars and somebody
still beat me I'm gonna have to play
hardball and I'm gonna bid $200 for this
early 2000s diary from Illinois let's
see how much it's really worth it is
people I won but I had to pay a hundred
and sixty dollars so I drove up the
price quite a bit let's hope there's
some murder in these Diaries and not
just like today I ate another bowl of
oatmeal these are the diaries of a
stranger dream whoa this is very
jam-packed with a lot of handwriting a
lot of very small handwriting we have no
idea who wrote these how old they were
what their gender was we don't know if
they're still alive I'm gonna take a
look inside
and give him a read and I'll get back to
you this diary still has a pen attached
so this was probably the pen that this
person used to write this so I emailed
the eBay seller to try to get some more
information on these Diaries and the
person who sold them definitely didn't
write them he said he bought them from
an estate sale that means that the
person who wrote them has possibly died
and this might be a dead person's pen
this handwriting is incredibly hard to
read so this is a challenge Thursday
January 4th 2001 didn't sleep well last
night watch some TV then went to post
office and after that to Walmart bought
three plastic bins and slimfast home at
1:00 p.m.
I'm definitely getting the impression
that this is a woman even just reading
the mundane details of somebody's life
it still feels very personal to be
reading I know this woman keeps writing
about someone named Mickey and I really
thought Mickey was a baby and I was like
why does this lady have a random baby in
her house named Mickey and then I
realized Mickey's a dog Mickey is a dog
Wednesday February 7th 2001 up at 8:30
Mickey very Restless all night long the
woman who wrote this diary has had to
endure some rude comments from someone
named Lydia and I think Lydia is either
her stepmom or her sister and basically
Lydia said you don't wear clothes well
that's mean and she says your stomach
sticks out your pants are too small
Tuesday January 9th 2001 watched Oprah
Friday February 9th 2001 slept well last
night but had a lousy day all I wanted
to do is sleep and eat I've been reading
the diary for days now and so far no
murders I'm starting to get the sense
that there will be no murders in this
diary it's a lot of drinking slimfast a
lot of going to Walmart a lot of
watching The Price is Right but hey
that's better than murdering let's be
honest from a moral standpoint the
handwriting is hard to read but the more
I read it the more I start to understand
it it's like my brain
figure it out the code I'm in her head
she's in my head
Saturday January 6 2001 up at 10:00
didn't sleep well Thursday February 8
2001 didn't sleep again last night she
writes down what time she wakes up she
writes down whether or not she slept
well oftentimes she doesn't sleep well
it's hard when you wake up in the
morning and you feel like crap and it
sounds like that's happening a lot for
her every single night she doesn't sleep
well it's just didn't sleep very well
didn't sleep again didn't sleep well
again didn't sleep again every time she
says I finally had a good night's sleep
I'm like good good finally I feel deeply
connected and I want everything to be ok
for this woman she keeps talking about
someone named Jake Jake calling and I
think that Jake Jake could be a son or
daughter Wednesday January 10th 2001 JJ
didn't call today I should call him
tomorrow
JJ get it together call your mom I've
just come across one of the more
exciting things that I've encountered in
this diary and that's diarrhea
October 10th 2002 I got up at 8:30 have
diarrhea again I'm inspired by this
because I've written in a diary before
and I don't think I would ever mention
that I have diarrhea and to be this
comfortable with yourself
to say I have diarrhea in your diary I
think we should all strive to be that
comfortable talking about diarrhea
almost every day she writes woke up with
Mickey Mickey is mentioned almost every
day so Mickey seems like a good dog
she's running errands she stops at
McDonald's she gets two happy meals one
for herself and one for Mickey the dog I
think she has Tuesday January 9th 2001
dad went downstairs so I tidied his room
and aired out his bed read paper after
Dad was finished had juice dad and I
watched prices right and then he ate his
breakfast Lydia got up and I had
slimfast while she had some oatmeal I
feel like what I'm learning from reading
these Diaries it's gonna sound cheesy
but I feel like you can learn something
from every person there's not a bunch of
exciting stuff
happening in here there's nothing crazy
and yet I still feel inspired by this
woman you know she's writing down all
her personal thoughts and she never once
as a negative thing about another person
and she makes her bed every day and I
just feel like I did not realize this
was gonna be such an emotional roller
coaster I honestly did not I would be so
cranky if I couldn't sleep all the time
and maybe she was I haven't found
anything mean or cranky written in five
years worth of Diaries I'm on the very
last journal in case you were wondering
wiki is still alive and well at the end
the very last entry
December 2nd 2006 says slept pretty good
on the couch by the fireplace I'm not
gonna cry again I am NOT gonna cry again
[Music]